fünfte plätze meine damen und herren
guten tag die bundeskanzlerin der
bayerische ministerpräsident und der
erste hamburger bürgermeister bericht
nehmen jetzt über die gerade zu ende
gegangenen beratungen
ja meine damen und herren wir haben
heute planmäßig wir schon lange
angekündigt unsere beratung zwischen den
ministerpräsidenten der bundesländer und
der bundesregierung fortgesetzt
und ich denke wir können auch heute
sagen dass wir die aller erste phase der
pandemie hinter uns haben
aber uns muss immer bewusst sein dass
wir damit trotzdem immer noch am anfang
der pandemie sind und noch eine lange
auseinandersetzung mit dem virus vor uns
haben
die zahlen die uns das robert koch
institut nun seit einigen tagen meldet
sind sehr erfreulich für das betonen wir
hatten ja gehofft vor 14 tagen dass wir
nach den ersten größeren öffnung
schritten insbesondere im bereich der
geschäfte solche zahlen sehen können sie
sind geringer als damals und ich bin
sehr froh persönlich dass das gelungen
ist die täglichen neuinfektionen sind
nicht mehr jeden tag im vierstelligen
bereich sondern an einigen tagen auch im
dreistelligen bereich der reproduktion
stunt und da 1 nur noch ein landkreis
hat einen wert von über 50 akuten fällen
pro 100.000 einwohnern und wir haben es
im großen ganzen geschafft die
ansteckungskette also die
infektionsketten auch nachverfolgen zu
können und das ist das ergebnis der
stärkung der arbeit der gesundheitsämter
und ich möchte die gelegenheit nutzen
den mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern
der gesundheitsämter dafür auch ganz
herzlich zu danken sie haben selten in
der geschichte der
blick so im fokus der aufmerksamkeit
gestanden wie das jetzt der fall ist und
deshalb stehen wir jetzt an einem punkt
an dem wir sagen können dass wir das
ziel die verbreitung des virus zu
verlangsamen erreicht haben
unser gesundheitssystem vor
überforderung schützen konnten
und dieses konnten wir erreichen weil
und das ist das haupt der hauptpunkt die
bürgerinnen und bürger
verantwortungsvoll ihr leben in zeiten
des virus gelebt haben sich auf die
beschränkungen eingelassen haben und
damit das leben anderer menschen
gerettet haben und die jetzige situation
macht es auch möglich dass wir heute mit
dem ministerpräsidenten auch über
weitere öffnungen beraten und
beschließen konnten wir haben in den
letzten tagen eine vielzahl von
konzepten der fachministerkonferenz
hinbekommen und wir haben auch eine
vielzahl von mitarbeit von verbänden und
vereinigungen und interessenvertretungen
gehabt und dafür will ich mich auch ganz
herzlich bedanken denn man sieht dass
sozusagen die hygienevorschriften die
fragen die wir zu beachten haben in
zeiten des virus einfach akzeptiert
werden und dass der alltag auf diese
bedingungen auch in vielen bereichen
umgestellt wird
wir haben heute sehr lange noch mal
darüber diskutiert was sind die dinge
die weiter geld sind bleiben und hier
ist es ganz klar darüber musste man
nicht lange diskutieren das dass der
mindestabstand von 1,5 metern ist das
dass der mund nasen schutz ist im
öffentlichen raum vor allen dingen im
öffentlichen personennahverkehr und in
den geschäften gegebenenfalls wird das
auch an einigen stellen noch in anderen
bereichen die jetzt wieder geöffnet
werden dann verpflichtend und wir haben
darüber gesprochen
dass das kontakt die kontakt
beschränkung natürlich auch ein
wesentliches element ist und haben
deshalb verabredet dass grundsätzlich
bis zum 5 juni solche kontakt
beschränkungen weiter gelten angesichts
der niedrigeren infektionszahlen soll
der aufenthalt im öffentlichen raum
jetzt nicht nur alleine mit den
angehörigen des eigenen hausstands oder
einer weiteren person möglich sein
sondern dass dies auch mit dem personen
eines weiteren hausstandes möglich sein
wird also der eigenen hausstand plus die
person eines weiteren hausstandes dürfen
sich gemeinsam im öffentlichen raum
aufhalten aber dass es immer noch eine
ganz klare beschränkung der kontakte
weil wir eben vermeiden wollen dass
infektionen sich schnell weiter
verbreiten bereits getroffene
entscheidung von einzelnen bundesländern
bleiben davon unberührt
wir haben angesichts der tatsache dass
es auch eine große vielfalt in
bestimmten einzelregelungen gibt wann
macht genau was auf die auch den
unterschiedlichen infektionsgeschehen
geschuldet ist aber auf der anderen
seite auch der föderalen vielfalt eine
sache gemeinsam beschlossen die für die
nächste zeit für mich maßgeblich und
wichtig ist wenn wir regionale
unterschiede haben und die haben der
wenn wir niedrigere infektionszahlen
haben dann müssen wir auch einen notfall
mechanismus haben indem wir sagen wenn
regional infektionsherde wieder
auftreten dann muss man dort auch
besondere maßnahmen wieder einsetzen
können das haben wir in den vergangenen
beschlüssen schon immer ganz allgemein
gesagt wir haben es jetzt noch einmal
verschärft und spezifiziert gefasst und
gesagt dass die länder sicherstellen
werden dass in landkreisen oder
kreisfreien städten bei denen kumulativ
mehr als 50 neuinfektionen pro 100000
einwohner inlet in den letzten sieben
tagen aufgetreten sind
ein konsequentes beschränkung konzept
entwickeln werden unter einbeziehung der
entsprechenden landesbehörden wenn das
ein lokalisiertes und klar eingegrenzt
bares infektionsgeschehen ist zb
bei einer einrichtung in einem
krankenhaus oder im pflegeheim
dann kann dieses beschränkung des
konzept nur diese einrichtung umfassend
wenn es aber ein verteiltes regionales
ausbruchsgeschehen ist bei denen die
infektionsketten unklar sind dann müssen
allgemeine beschränkungen regional
wieder konsequent eingeführt werden und
zwar so lange bis wieder sieben
aufeinanderfolgende tage der wert unter
diese 50 akuten fälle pro 100.000
einwohner sinkt ich will darauf
hinweisen dass wir zurzeit nur einen
einzigen landkreis in deutschland haben
in dem das infektionsgeschehen größer
als 50 akute fälle pro 100.000 einwohner
ist wir haben dann noch einmal über die
tracing abgesprochen an der ja noch
entwickelt wird und wir haben noch
einmal das schulkonzept heute beraten
das die kultusminister verabredet haben
und mehr den rang zwei dinge gemacht die
mir sehr wichtig sind
das eine ist eben schule aber vor allen
dingen auch kindertagesstätten
ausweitung der notbetreuung denn wir
wissen dass die kinder mit recht auch
wieder in ihr normales leben so weit wie
möglich zurück wollen das dauert aber
die bundesländer haben hier ja jetzt
auch konzepte vorbereitet bei denen das
zunehmend möglich ist und eine gruppe
ist mir von ganz besonderer wichtigkeit
und das sind die älteren menschen die in
den pflegeheimen jetzt seit wochen jetzt
auch besucher zum großen teil verzichten
müssen aus diesen heimen und
einrichtungen nicht hinausgehen können
und wir wissen was das bedeutet oder an
ist auch nur und diese menschen haben
einen anspruch darauf dass wir auch in
zeiten von öffnungen an sie denken und
deshalb war es mir sehr wichtig dass
darauf hingewirkt wird das eine feste
kontaktperson wieder regelmäßig zugang
zu den pflegebedürftigen oder den
menschen mit demenz oder den behinderten
personen
in behinderteneinrichtungen auch haben
kann
wir haben dann eine vielzahl von anderen
bereichen noch behandelt unter anderem
das thema geschäfte die jetzt ohne
begrenzung aber natürlich mit den
hygiene konzepten öffnen können über den
breiten und freizeitsport genauso wie
über die erste zweite fußball-bundesliga
die auf der zweiten maihälfte wieder den
spielbetrieb unter den genehmigten und
ja auch getesteten regeln führen darf
und wir haben dann gesagt dass die
länder in ihrem bereich viele andere
bereiche die ich jetzt hier nicht
erwähnen möchte mit einem konzept mit
einem zukunftskonzept entwickeln werden
und dann die jeweiligen öffnungszeiten
schritt für schritt natürlich umsetzen
können
wichtig ist mir noch dass ein konzept
auch für theater- opern- und
konzerthäuser und kinos entwickelt wird
da haben wir die staatsministerin für
kultur mit den kultusministern gebeten
denn wir haben jetzt ja durch religiöse
veranstaltung zum beispiel schon
vorbildhaft möglichkeiten dass solche
veranstaltungen auch wieder stattfinden
können alles in allem haben wir eine
sehr konstruktive diskussion gehabt
angesichts der fülle reihen vielfalt
nicht verwunderlich dass es da durchaus
auch unterschiedliche akzente immer gibt
das gehört dazu
ich will noch mal ganz deutlich sagen
dass überall und das ist heute in den
beratungen aber auch von allen sagt
worden die hygienevorschriften
eingehalten werden müssen das heißt in
der gastronomie natürlich zum beispiel
dass nicht nur zwei tische voneinander
zwei meter entfernt sein müssen sondern
dass wenn nicht die person von zwei haus
stellen am tisch sitzen das dann eben
auch die
dafür gesorgt werden muss dass der
sicherheitsabstand eingehalten wird
denn wenn ein 50 zentimeter breiter
tisch von beiden seiten mit einer person
jeweils einer person besetzt wird dann
ist das für jene fonds es nicht
eingehalten das wird eine riesen
herausforderung sein auch für die
bereiche die jetzt öffnen
und trotzdem hat uns geleitet dass es
besser ist die kommenden schritte voraus
und geben natürlich auch perspektiven
sowohl in der schule als auch in der
kita als auch in anderen bereichen als
dass wir gar nicht vorangehen und wir
haben das ist für mich eben entscheidend
nicht nur den weg zu mehr öffnung
sondern wir haben auch einen gemeinsame
klammer die sagt wenn irgendwo etwas
passiert wenn irgendwo infektionen nach
oben geht dann haben wir auch einen
notfallmechanismus und dann muss nicht
eine ganzes land sozusagen wieder in die
gefahr kommen dass wir zurückgehen
müssen sondern einzelne regionen und
insgesamt ist das für mich jetzt ein
ausgewogener beschluss sehr verehrten
damen und herren wenn man eine
zwischenbilanz zu corona ziel und wir
haben jetzt dass solche
pressekonferenzen macht regelmäßige
updates dann kann man sagen dass es
schon ein leichtes aufatmen geben kann
als wir vor einigen wochen jetzt
zusammen gekommen sind war die lage viel
viel bedrohlicher waren die aussichten
lesen nicht düsterer und man darf schon
mal an so einem tag bei aller sorge
bleibt auch froh und dankbar darüber
sein wie es bislang bei uns im land
verlaufen ist dass die zahlen sich so
entwickeln wie in den letzten tagen und
wochen und deswegen zum einmal ein
persönlicher aber auch im namen glaube
ich viele andere kollegen und kollegen
ein dankeschön an die bevölkerung denn
sie hat mitgemacht sie ist der
entscheidende grund und gradmesser
gewesen warum das funktioniert hat dass
wir besser jedenfalls als andere länder
bislang durch diese krise gekommen sind
ich glaube man kann sagen deutschland
ist deswegen auch so gut durchgekommen
weil wir die strategie eine richtige
strategie hatten weil wir sie gemeinsam
auch verantwortung bund und länder
jeder in seinem bereich in seiner
verantwortung und dass wir die geduld
bewahrt haben in dieser schwierigen zeit
also die zahlen sind positiv selbst in
den ländern die ein größeres
infektionsgeschehen haben die
beispielsweise bei uns in bayern
wenn man es anschaut
haben jetzt eine situation dass noch
mehr tägliches wachstum von circa 0,5
prozent haben wir hatten mal fast 30
prozent am tag der reproduktions faktor
ist dauerhaft unter 12 07
und wenn man das umrechnet auf die
gesamtbevölkerung sind bei uns derzeit
nur noch 0,05 prozent überhaupt
infizierte aktuell da ist aber kein
anlass
bei aller freude und leicht auf abend
ist kein anlass nachzulassen
die sorge bleibt das kann sich jederzeit
wieder verändern
es ist immer noch wichtig darauf
hinzuweisen solange wir keinen impfstoff
haben
solange keine medikamente haben so lange
bleibt diese gefahr dar und kann
jederzeit sich erneut entwickeln darum
ist das wichtigste an den gemeinsamen
strategien die wir reden nicht nur
einfach zu öffnen sondern gleichzeitig
grundlinien zu behalten was vorsicht und
umsicht betrifft und drückst du die
beschlüsse heute nicht nur fragen wie
erleichtert ich das ganze sondern wie
kann ich im zweifelsfall auch die
sicherheit weiter gewährleisten wir
wissen dass das ein schweres abwägen ist
immer zwischen den sicherheitsbegriff
und dem freiheitsbegriff und wir spüren
auch in der bevölkerung das ist zwei
gruppen gibt gibt er fast ein bisschen
so die einen die sind zu besorgten geht
es zu schnell und in anderen kann es
nicht schnell genug gehen
in diesem dilemma versuchen wir einen
verantwortungsvollen fahrt der
besonnenheit und vernunft aber auch des
respekts vor freiheit und normalität
zueinander zu bringen
und ich glaube alle länder tun dass
gemeinschaftlich in den jeweiligen
bewusstsein
ich bedanke mich noch mal persönlich
übrigens auch dass viele bundesländer
wohl sie ein sehr niedriges
infektionsgeschehen hatten fielen
niedriger als andere
tschentscher und ich wir sind der länder
die stark betroffen sind wegen skifahren
zum beispiel gab es dann ein
infektionsgeschehen das auf brach bei
uns per watt fahrer bei ihnen hat sich
seiner wahl auch niedergeschlagen und
andere länder die weniger hatten waren
trotzdem sehr solidarisch maßnahmen das
sind glaube ich hat sich der
föderalismus an der stelle
zusammen mit dem bund und auch der
führung durch den bund glaube ich sehr
sehr als wirksam erwiesen
sie sollten wir bei diesen weg weiter
gehen also zusammenzuführen die
gesellschaft freiheit zu ermöglichen
aber trotzdem mit sicherheit nicht zu
vernachlässigen
deswegen brauchen wir langfristige pläne
deswegen haben wir heute auch vereinbart
uns nicht wieder im wochenrhythmus zu
treffen sondern längeren zeitachse mit
perspektiven auf der basis der
fachminister die jeweiligen
entscheidungen der bundesländer sind
nicht weit auseinander aber ein bisschen
dürfen sie auch sein weil die spezifika
unterschiedlich sind bei uns
beispielsweise immer noch mehr
infizierte haben als andere wollen wir
langsamer vorgehen später manches öffnen
aber die jeweiligen abstände sozusagen
den zeitachsen verändern nicht oder
bedeutet nicht dass man insgesamt nichts
tun würde
für uns bleibt ist darf ich sagen
gemeinschaftlicher der maßstab der
oberste maßstab die vernunft und die
sorge dass kein rückfall passiert darum
ist die notbremse die wir jetzt
vereinbart haben die notbremse ist das
was sozusagen das robert koch institut
mit der bundesregierung den ländern
ermittelten als zahl die sind notbremse
das ist sozusagen die notfall police
wenn diese zahl ein trend von einer zahl
von infizierten 100.000 dann muss man
einschreiten der wichtiges wenn man dann
rechtzeitig einschreiten zwar regional
können mit regionalen pandemieplänen und
damit mehr personal mehr tests mit mehr
containment ford kann ausbreitung
verhindert und damit auch verhindert
werden dass erneut locker und für das
ganze land notwendig ist also die
regionale differenziert hat aufgrund des
unterschiedlichen ausbruchsgeschehens
wird uns helfen eine zielgerichtete und
passgenauer situationen antwort zu
ermöglichen für jeden einzelnen und für
jede region und es musste ich das ganze
land diesen weg dann jeweils gehen
deswegen ist diese zeigen notbremse
heute beschluss das wichtigste und das
zentrale element neben vielen fragen der
öffnung sozusagen wie man das macht wenn
man weiter geht wenn man sich öffnet
wenn man mehr freiheit hat hat man aber
auch die sicherheit jederzeit zielgenau
reagieren zu können ich kann nur sagen
ich weiß es von der bundesgrenze schaut
sich jeden tag auch die landkreis zahlen
an und weiß genau bescheid im fragt nach
warum in dem landkreis und dem landkreis
die zahlen so oder so sieht also was wir
jetzt tun ist uns entwickeln
eröffnen aber nicht überstürzt mit
bedacht welche elemente waren heute noch
mal wichtig das erste ist aber auch
wichtig die vorsorge muss bleiben
wir dürfen auf keinen fall nachlassen in
der ausweitung und verbesserung des
gesundheitssystems
es wäre jetzt ein schwerer fehler wenn
wir den begonnenen anstrengungen auf
halber strecke einstellen
dazu gehört die gesundheitsämter mit
qualifiziertem fachpersonal weiter
auszustatten und ehrlicherweise auch ein
stück weit besser zu bezahlen als in
vergangen dabei war es muss eine der top
jobs seien beim start
zweitens die intensivbetten mit beatmung
wir haben bayern jetzt in der kürze der
zeit um 31% schon erhöht dies muss auf
die 50 prozent ankommen
wir werden es im zweifelsfall dringend
brauchen unser bisheriges 100 systeme
den stresstest bestanden
es kann jederzeit wiederkommen dafür
müssen wir vorbereitet sein
das gleiche gilt für material es ist
zweiter sinnvoll masken schutzausrüstung
genau in der form geraten weiter zu
bestellen und auch zu lagern für
notfallreserven werden es zukünftig
haben mit medikamenten machen und wir
müssen die forschung in der frage weiter
intensivieren wir fahren jeden tag mehr
und wir brauchen jeden tag auch mehr
informationen zum auf infektionen dieser
art weitere erklärt zu können das zweite
die mutter aller fragen ist die kontakt
beschränkung da kein impfstoff kein
medikament bleibt die kontakt
beschränkung die einzige echte antwort
die frage wie man das jeweils wo macht
die hygiene ist das zweite aber die
kernfrage ist dass wir haben uns heute
glaube ich einfach nochmal sehr guten
kompromiss geeinigt kontakt beschränkung
heißt man muss distanz halten
man kann aber dort wo es dann verfolgbar
ist wo es nachvollziehbare neben der
eigenen familie
während bayern kann das auch für die
verwandtschaft jetzt ermöglicht oma opa
schwester geschwister oder auch die
eltern am werk sagt wenn sich eine
familie mit einer anderen familie trifft
mit einem anderen haus stammt dann
irgendwann mal gemeinsam essen gehen
oder sich trifft das ist ja
nachvollziehbar
dann glaube ich kann man das machen und
es ist auch der lebensrealität
entsprechend worum es uns geht sind
keine unkontrollierten partys gruppen
und großen ansammlungen ermöglichen ist
hinterher nicht ein mögliches
infektionsgeschehen nachzuvollziehen
wenn die nachvollziehbarkeit fehlt ist
infektions ausbruch relativ schnell
wieder vor der tür deswegen glaube ich
lebenswirklichkeit familien ständehaus
stände die sich treffen können aber
nicht darüber hinaus
dann haben wir uns und es begrüßen wir
natürlich auch sehr da haben viele
länder schon vorschläge gemacht sehr
gute übrigens und wir lernen auch als
länder voneinander
jeder dieser konferenz ist auch ein
austausch was macht der eine was machen
die anderen und das zu stärken was kita
und schule betrifft ich glaube da
brauchen wir natürlich der ganze familie
im bereich ist neben den fragen wie
gastro und handeln es ist auch nicht der
befinden familie ist immer der zentrale
bereich weil er das leben der menschen
wirklich mehr prägt die mehrzahl der
fragen die wir hatten waren von bürgern
wie geht es weiter mit der
kinderbetreuung wann fängt die schule
wieder an und nicht die erste frage wann
tritt wieder im biergarten so wichtig
dass auch ist haben die länder
verschiedene vorschläge
wir haben bei uns zum beispiel gesagt
vor pfingsten dann wie es organisieren
können unter beachtung aller
hygienemaßnahmen dass 50 prozent der
kinder in der not betreuung wieder in
die kita können und 50 prozent auch
wieder in die schule können mit all den
maßnahmen unterricht entsprechend
geteilt kleinere gruppen wir dann sogar
in bayern an der an der schule eine
masten pflicht einführen nicht im
unterricht aber sozusagen im schulalltag
pausenhof schul gänge sanitäre
einrichtungen weil dort ist weniger
steuerbar ist und es ist wichtig dass
wir auf den eltern sagen können das ist
zwar kein normales schuljahr aber es
darf auf keinen fall ein verlorenes
schuljahr sein dass es die abschlüsse
die gemacht werden dürfen nicht ewig
unter dem stigma stehen das ist eine
krone habe ein hoher und mittlerer reife
sondern muss auf dem gleichen niveau
stehen es werden alle länder garantieren
oder engagieren sich auch die
bildungspolitiker sehr und die
bundeskanzlei hat noch mal angesprochen
ist mit den senioren auch das ist
wichtig jetzt wir haben am sonntag
muttertag ich glaube das ist schon sehr
wichtig dass auch die möglichkeit
bestehen muss dort dass sich familien
sehen können allerdings auch unter sehr
sehr hohen schutz auflagen und auch mit
der konzentration auf schutzausrüstungen
die wir in den bereichen auch für die
mitarbeiter
mitarbeiter brauchen bei gastro haben
die länder wie in vielen anderen
bereichen etwas unterschiedliche akzente
die ein machen es etwas früher
wir machen es deutlich später allerdings
gibt es dort gute vorschläge aus den
jeweiligen regionen das ganze anzugeben
letzter punkt aus meiner sicht noch der
vorletzte und fußball haben uns auch
geeinigt glaube ich jetzt in einem
vernünftigen vernünftigen einigung
wir wissen auch dass der sehr kontrovers
ist übrigens ich halte diesen kompromiss
für mehr als vertretbar ich kann aber
nur eines appellieren
ich weiß dass die verantwortlichen in
den bundesligavereinen alles tun werden
um sicherheit zu erreichen
aber es sollten auch spieler die sich
unvernünftig verhalten auch mit
konsequenzen rechnen müssen
denn das war die woche von dem ein
spieler von hertha bsc schon schweres
eigentor für das bemühen
hygienemaßnahmen die alle treffen wollen
und es haben sich nicht nur normale
menschen an alle hygienemaßnahmen zu
halten sondern auch diejenigen die sehr
viel verdienen und auch privileg haben
deswegen sollte das auch für alle
gleichzeitig gelten am schluss noch mal
1 1 1 dank für die zwischen etappe auch
noch einen bunt da war jetzt die letzten
tage die debatte ist es jetzt gegen
grund oder für bund mein eindruck ist
dass jeder der eine maßnahme trifft und
sie sind noch unterschiedlich hat der
länder macht es in gemeinschaftlichen
bewusst sein dass wir etwas mehr als
sicherheit erreichen wollen
jeder von uns die bundeskanzlei
tschentscher durch wir finden uns
täglich im spannungsfeld zwischen dem
wunsch nach normalität und freiheit aber
der gleichzeitigen sorgen um die
sicherheit der bevölkerung und diese
abwägung wird täglich getroffen und ich
glaube dass wir heute wieder einen guten
schritt vorangekommen sind nur wir haben
uns jetzt auch ausdrücklich wir nehmen
uns etwas zeit quasi bis zum juni hinein
um diese ganzen fragen zu klären damit
wir uns auch nicht woche für woche unter
druck setzen obwohl wir gar nicht
richtig beurteilen können wie sich
einzelne öffnungen auf das
infektionsgeschehen ausbrechen denn dann
ist schon wichtig nicht immer etwas
beschließen bevor wir nicht wissen ob es
angriffe deswegen lieber langfristig
planen dann kurzfristig entscheiden
passen die zahlen geht mehr passen die
zahl nicht muss man möglicherweise
verlangsamen oder etwas nicht machen was
man sich gerne gewünscht hätte also
nochmal vielen dank für das gute
miteinander
wir haben in den letzten zwei monaten
gesehen in deutschland wie schnell sich
das saas kopf 2 virus ausbreiten kann
mit sehr sehr hohen instanzen in
baden-württemberg und bayern saarland
bei uns in hamburg
sie haben wir dann auch gesehen dass
konsequente maßnahmen dazu führen können
dass wir das auch wieder eindecken
wir haben in hamburg jetzt niedrige
zweistellige infektionszahlen pro tag
das ist ein sehr großer erfolg und wir
haben vereinbarungsgemäß heute dann
beschlossen dass wir die nächsten
schritte gehen in den bereichen kita
schule und sport auf grundlage von
konzepten der fachministerkonferenz wir
haben dazu gesagt dass dies auch gelten
soll für die gastronomie und den das
beherbergungsgewerbe mit ersten
schritten und wir haben dann entschieden
und das ist neu dass wir die weiteren
schritte dann in die verantwortung der
länder liegen
das ist eine große verantwortung jetzt
kommt bei allen schritten nämlich darauf
an dass wir weiterhin darauf achten dass
die maßgaben die bedingung für die
weiteren schritte so sind das ist nicht
wieder zu einem starken anstieg der
infektionszahlen kommt und deswegen
übernehmen die länder heute keine sehr
große verantwortung für die bereiche die
wir angesprochen haben und für das was
noch dazu kommt
denn auch das ist ja eine erkenntnis
dass wenn wir alles schon geregelt sehen
dass es noch sehr viele dinge gibt die
auch bedeutsam sind die in den nächsten
wochen geregelt werden müssen deswegen
ist der auftrag an die entsprechenden
fach ministerkonferenzen auch für die
noch nicht mit guten perspektiven
ausgestatteten bereiche konzepte zu
entwickeln die die länder dann in ihrer
eigenen verantwortung umsetzen können
es wird dazu kommen das kann man
föderale vielfalt nennen aber es wird
eben auch dazu kommen dass die
massnahmen regional sehr unterschiedlich
dann ausgestaltet sind ihre
berichterstattung warum ist heute in
diesem bundesland so und drei tage
später woanders noch an
das ist etwas was es jetzt geben wird
das steckt in dieser vereinbarung drin
dass wir jetzt den ländern diese
verantwortung übergeben und ich hoffe
für uns alle dass die länder diese
verantwortung auch gut tragen
dann kommen ihre fragen frau dunst frau
bundeskanzlerin sie haben vor zwei
wochen gesagt dass manche
ministerpräsidenten zu forsch voran
gehen wie würden sie das tempo
bezeichnen das da seit samstag
angekommen ist haben sie noch ein gutes
gefühl dass die bürger bundesweit ein
überblick behalten und herr tschentscher
es hat ja wohl unterschiedliche
auffassungen zwischen
spd-ministerpräsidenten und unions
ministerpräsidenten über den start der
bundesliga gegeben
wiewohl ist ihnen dabei diesem
einflussreichen sport eine derartige
extrawurst zu braten und andere dann
nicht mitzunehmen vor uns wir haben eine
sehr sehr gute entwicklung der neue
infektionszahlen und die ermöglicht es
schon weitere schritte zu gehen
wir müssen darauf aufpassen dass uns die
sache nicht entgleitet und ich habe
deshalb ein recht gutes gefühl weil wir
heute eben auch diesen notfall
mechanismus gefunden haben und nicht nur
sagen was wir auch machen sondern eben
auch sagen wenn lokal etwas passiert
dann warten wir nicht bis sich das durch
die gesamte republik verbreitet hat
sondern dann handeln wir lokal für
andere so wie wir menschen bitten ihre
eigene ihr eigenes leben einzuschränken
um anderer menschenleben zu retten so
bitten wir jetzt einfach auch regionen
wo sowas auftreten sollte für andere
regionen auch die weitere öffnung
möglich zu machen und insofern glaube
ich gehen der schon einen mutigen weg
das glaube ich also man kann nicht sagen
dass wir jetzt nicht die interessen
von besuchen von kontakten aber auch von
wirtschaftsunternehmen im auge haben ich
will bei der gelegenheit noch einmal
daran erinnern war ja auch oft aus der
wirtschaft kritik kommt wir haben in
weiten teilen der wirtschaft keinerlei
verbote verhält wenn man gestern mit der
automobilindustrie zum beispiel
gesprochen natürlich hat sich das
kaufverhalten der menschen geändert das
ist klar
in dieser krise aber im vergleich zu
anderen ländern wo die halbe produktion
stillgelegt ist ist deutschland da
eigentlich immer einen sehr offenen und
mutigen weg gegangen also wir können uns
ein stück mut leisten aber wir müssen
vorsichtig bleiben und durch diesen
notfall mechanismus haben wir diese
möglichkeit der vorsicht und wir haben
auch ein ausgewogenes konzept wir haben
an die älteren gedacht wir haben an die
familien gedacht wir haben werden jetzt
kultur konzepte bekommen war ja auch ein
bisschen die diskussion war denkt man
jetzt nur daran wo wirtschaftsbereiche
betroffen sind
insofern gehe ich in die nächsten tage
und sage wir beobachten dass das
sicherlich kritischste ist das hotel und
gaststättengewerbe gaststätten habe ich
schon gesagt wegen der größeren nähe da
muss man auf die hygiene konzepte sehr
achten und bei der beherbergung ist es
natürlich so man fährt nicht ins hotel
neben seiner eigenen wohnung sondern da
kommt es natürlich dann wieder zu mehr
reiseverkehr durch die republik das
heißt die sehr unterschiedlichen
infektionsgeschehen lokal werden kommen
in kontakt miteinander und diesem
prozess werden sehr sehr gut beobachten
müssen was bedeutet das um was für das
nach sich wie sie wissen wissen wir dass
immer erst 14 tage bis drei wochen
später
der beschluss zur bundesliga ist
einstimmig erfolgt also so wie es hier
steht das wird von allen getragen
ich kann für die spd ministerpräsidenten
sagen aber ich glaube das gilt genauso
für die b seite und zwar schon wichtig
dass wir nicht den profisport jetzt neue
möglichkeiten geben und den amateursport
dabei vergessen und deswegen gilt ja ab
sofort dass wir das sportminister
konzept jetzt umsetzen wollen das eben
große lockerungsschritte auch für den
amateur sport
für den individual sport im freien ist
das schon in der letzten woche
geschlossen worden oder es ist schon
umgesetzt worden in vielen ländern
wir haben jetzt diese sportminister
konzept in der nächsten stufe ausgelöst
das heißt es wird weitere möglichkeiten
geben für den amateur spart nach diesem
konzept und in diesem zusammenhang ist
dann diese regelung für den profisport
für die bundesliga die eine große
fangemeinde hat wo es ja viele gibt die
auch darauf warten diese spiele wieder
sehen zu können ist dieser beschluss
dann am ende wirklich einstimmig und
einvernehmlich getroffen worden
er plant die pr frau bundeskanzlerin mit
blick auf die kontakt beschränkungen
heißt das bei der zwei haushalte regel
denn jetzt nun dass in den nächsten
feiertagen zum beispiel kinder wieder zu
ihren großeltern fahren können oder dass
da die familien zusammengeführt werden
können oder sehen sie da eher ein anlass
dem noch abzuraten irgendwo weil die
schwierigkeiten sind ja nicht geringer
geworden und eine frage an herrn söder
wenn ich darf was die bundesliga angeht
sie haben ja in ihrem beschluss
drinstehen das vor der aufnahme des
spielbetriebs eine quarantäne stehen
soll
es gibt keinen datum aber wenn man die
quarantäne auf zwei wochen zieht dann
ist der beginn der fußball bundesliga
nicht vor dem 21
und was macht es für einen sinn
quarantäne zu beschließen wenn nach dem
ersten spiel gar keine quarantäne mehr
ist also was die kontakt beschränkungen
anbelangt so gilt ja nichts anderes
jetzt als es eigentlich vorher war es
nur eine einzige person zu dem eigenen
hausstand hinzukommen dürfte jetzt
darauf einen ausstand zu einem haus
stand dazu kommen trotzdem hat mir
gesagt dass enkel und großeltern oder
jüngere und ältere besondere besonderen
schutz brauchen was hat sich jetzt ja
nicht verändert wenn man das
verantwortlich macht dann kann können
sicherlich auch kinder sich mit ihren
eltern treffen aber dieser besondere
schutz für ältere weil sie eben einfach
auch eine risikogruppe sind der geest
hier genauso wie er bei pflegeheimen
wo wir sagen trotzdem soll eine
konstante kontaktpersonen zugang haben
also man kann ja nicht eine ganze
generation ohne menschliche kontakte
lassen das heißt aber dass die besondere
aufmerksamkeit auf ältere natürlich
trotzdem bestehen bleibt also bei der
bei der bundesliga steht der in
quarantäne
die quarantäne muss aber nicht zwei
wochen sein sollte oder der
bundesgesundheitsminister gesagt die
kann auch kürzer sein und überdies von
den entsprechenden behörden entsprechend
umgesetzt wiederholen was da dort
regelmäßig getestet wird ist natürlich
eine andere situation als wenn jemand
nur einmal am beginn einer kantine und
einmal am ende einer quarantäne getestet
wird das ist glaube ich der hintergrund
warum diese 14 tage nicht so explizit
aufgeführt sind
beim medizinischen personal mit einer
testung sind sie dann sehr sicher dass
es zu einer infektion übertragen kommen
kann
da drücken geht es weiter hieß die eine
frage frau bundeskanzlerin herr söder
hat gestern gesagt wir haben corona
unter kontrolle teilen sie diese
einschätzung und gab es einen dissenz
bei den zahlen 35 und 50 neuinfektionen
denn heute war nur 50 gegenstand der
gespräche wir haben uns das nochmal
überlegt früher gab es mal die auch die
betrachtung 35 aber wir haben es jetzt
angeschaut was sind die gesundheitsämter
was sind wie sind sie bestückt wir haben
pro 20.000 einwohner ein team von fünf
leuten kann man die infektionsketten
verfolgen und wir glauben dass man das
bis zu 50 akut infizierten pro tag wenn
man es dann über sieben tage ermittelt
dass man das erreichen kann und leisten
kann und auf dieser grundlage gab es
heute da keinen keine große diskussion
ist wurde darauf hingewiesen dass die
situation in einem landkreis
unterschiedlich ist von einer großstadt
das ist klar deshalb wird auch niemand
warten wenn man heute bei zehn
infizierten pro 100000 einwohner ist
dass mann seelenruhig zukunft essmann 48
erreicht hat sondern sicher wird jeder
sich genau überlegen wenn er ein
stärkeres infektionsgeschehen sieht wie
das der fall ist und hatten
na ja wir haben zurzeit mit den
infektionszahlen die wir aufweisen
können eine situation wo wir es
einigermaßen unter kontrolle haben würde
ich sagen aber das ist immer eine
momentaufnahme und jetzt mit jeder
kontakt erweiterung müssen wir wieder
gucken ob das so bleibt und wir stehen
jetzt vor einer phase in der natürlich
sehr viel mehr kontakte stattfinden
werden als das bisher der fall war und
ob wir das dann in dieser phase wieder
so haben das wissen wir noch nicht
deshalb eben auch diese dieser notfall
mechanismus aber wir stellen ja die
kontakte auch nicht einfach wieder her
wie sie früher waren sondern alle sind
mit hygienemaßnahmen mit
sicherheitsabständen und wenn sich daran
alle
dann wird das auch gibt es eine
vernünftige chance dass es so bleibt
sonst würden wir das ja nicht
verantwortlich entscheiden ich habe
gesagt wir gehen mutig vor
aber wir glauben dass wir mit den rand
bedingungen unter denen wir das zulassen
eine chance haben allerdings das will
ich dann noch mal sagen sind wir fast
noch mehr auf dieses mitmachen der
menschen angewiesen denn ohne das
mitmachen der menschen sind alle unsere
bedingungen oder unsere maßnahmen
natürlich nicht nicht wirksam und
deshalb jedes stück freiheit was möglich
ist muss unter diesen bedingungen des
virus verantwortungsbewusst von jedem
einzelnen menschen genutzt werden und
wir finden immer wieder alle das zu tun
denn wenn es jeder tut ist es für alle
gemeinsam besser bei münstermann
dankeschön frau bundeskanzlerin ich habe
eine frage zu dem notfall mechanismus
der dann greifen soll wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe geht nix in die
einzelnen länder die dann entscheiden
hier stimmt was nicht wir müssen handeln
aber sollte sich das in vielen
bundesländern
der fall sein mehr als zurzeit ab wann
kommt dann der bund wieder ins spiel
also sprechen sie sich ab untereinander
oder ist es jetzt wirklich jeder
regierungschef der länder der sagt ich
schwer den landkreis aber das leben
sonst kann genauso weitergehen
na ja wir haben ein hohes maß an
transparenz sie kennen alle unsere diese
karten die veröffentlicht werden wo dann
die landkreise auch gekennzeichnet sind
und wir haben sagen hier ja auch dieses
dass die länder die konzepte machen aber
das robert koch institut informieren und
sie können wir davon ausgehen dass mit
hilfe auch der öffentlichen diskussion
werden aus plötzlich aus einem landkreis
hier 50 wären in deutschland dass das
schon diskussionen auslösen wird über
die wo dann natürlich auch der bund
wieder ins spiel kommt und das robert
koch institut ist ja auch eine
institution die sehr eng mit den ländern
zusammenarbeiten also ich glaube hier
wird sehe ich eigentlich kein problem
und ich glaube dass wir hier auch wenn
man jetzt mal sich ein vierteljahr
zurück denkt eine ganz andere situation
haben dass man einfach mit einer ganz
anderen aufmerksamkeit und mit einer
ganz anderen detailgenauigkeit jetzt
auch verfolgt was passiert wo und selbst
und gesundheitsamts bezirk ist ja noch
eine riesen sache also ich meine bayern
hatte mark böschen reuth abgeregelt so
ein bisschen von der welt es kann auch
sein dass man da nur einen ort nimmt
weil dort das infektionsgeschehen so
besonders groß ist und insofern glaube
ich dass wir da in einem guten
miteinander hinkommen das ganze und eine
westbalkan video-konferenz muss denke
ich schaffen wir nur noch zwei fragen
die nächste wäre hätte
danke ganz kurz der bdi herrschen gleich
getötet die deutsche wirtschaft ist
ready for restart frau bundeskanzlerin
muss jetzt war ja alles ein bisschen
vorgezogen wird an lockerungen muss
jetzt auch möglicherweise das
wiederaufbauprogramm für die deutsche
wirtschaft auch die hilfen für die
autoindustrie möglicherweise auch
vorgezogen werden das war ja jetzt
glaube ich der letzte stand war anfang
juni wo man darüber beraten wollte der
bayerische ministerpräsident ische mitte
mai gesagt muss das jetzt alles etwas
vorgezogen werden
also wir werden das in der woche nach
pfingsten vereinbaren wir müssen uns ja
auch erstmal anschauen welche
wirtschaftsbereiche haben auch oft eine
längere strecke jetzt noch keine chance
wieder wegen des großen
publikumsverkehrs überhaupt in gang zu
kommen ansonsten kann die wirtschaft
starten ich glaube nicht man kann von
einem restart der deutschen wirtschaft
nur dann sprechen wenn die
bundesregierung sozusagen noch eine
schippe drauflegt wir werden ein
konjunkturprogramm brauchen aber der
start erfolgt natürlich auch in der
wirtschaft selber aber es ist schon
wichtig dass wir jetzt zum teil eben
perspektiven für bestimmte bereiche
haben
damit ist aber ja zum beispiel noch
nicht der alte zustand wiederhergestellt
und selbst wenn das gast- und die
gastronomie wieder öffnet wenn die
hotels wieder öffnen dann werden sie ja
nicht 100 prozent der belegung haben wir
werden bereiche haben in denen das noch
eine sehr lange zeit nur einschränkungen
auf der tagesordnung sind das werden wir
uns überlegen bis anfang juni
da haben wir in festen plan und das
halte ich schon von der zeit vom
zeitablauf her für sehr ehrgeizig wir
haben heute den 6
das geht schneller als man denkt das
muss gut überlegt sein und die letzte
frage herr jordan sap
ja frau bundeskanzlerin ich habe immer
noch nicht ganz verstanden wer das
eigentlich jetzt überwacht wer sitzt an
der notbremse denn ihr beschluss
beinhaltet die haben eine große portion
vertrauen dass in jedem land überwand
kreis alle notwendigen maßnahmen
getroffen werden wie wollen sie da
verhindern dass fälle übersehen werden
und dann ein neuer fall wie in ischgl
auftaucht also die ganze bundesrepublik
ist aufgebaut auf vertrauen
das gesamte infektionsschutzgesetz ist
ein gesetz was durch die länder
vollzogen wird was von den örtlichen
gesundheitsämtern gemacht wird die tests
finden vor ort statt
und ich habe mir noch nie die frage
gestellt ob ein gesundheitsamt
vielleicht die zahl der infizierten
irgendwie nicht real wieder gibt es ist
auch in unserem gemeinsamen interesse
und wenn sie wenn sie nur noch der
zentrale vertrauen können und einen
anderen eher im land nicht dann
widerspricht das unserem
demokratieverständnis ich vertraue den
bürgerinnen und bürger vertrauen ist der
grundsatz und dann muss man natürlich ab
und zu auch kontrollieren das ist klar
aber dass wenn wenn wir dieses vertrauen
nicht mehr haben dass landräte
bürgermeister gesundheitsämter gut
arbeiten dann ja dann können wir
einpacken
das ist dann nicht unsere bundesrepublik
deutschland
[Musik]